foreign
welcome to legislative Administration
for the folks that have never been here
um welcome thank you for helping us uh
handle this um
very
low priority uh project that we've got
going just to clean up two bills
um we have two to handle uh House Bill
1368 which is relative to recusable by
members of the general court for
conflicts of interest
and hcr9 which is expressing the
appreciation of the general court to
Nicole Knox Murphy for her song My 603.
UM
I'm not sure how many people I think
pretty much everyone understands the
process we have here we have only two
items
um this is a binary choice of recommend
or not recommend for future legislation
um
I'll just go in order and start with
House Bill 1368 relative to reusable by
members of the general court for
conflicts of interest
I would be we are dealing only with the
concept here not with the the
actual bill itself and I'd be looking
for
a
motion
representative Wallace thank you Mr
chairman I recommend the bill for future
legislation
they're a second
I'll second it
seconded by representative Sheehan you
have that
any discussion
since you're a sponsor on the bill do
you would you like to well I do feel we
need future legislation oh
all right there's this big problem
there's been a big problem for a long
time in terms of when people should
recuse and not recuse and
um I really respect the fact that the
bill was brought in essentially by um
representative Ned Gordon initially the
Ethics Committee has asked for
clarification and some type of
legislation to make this more workable
and so I would support
future legislation
thank you
you made the motion representative
Wallace anything to say
I think she covered it quite well let's
move the question I thought you would
say that
um I will only add one thing from the
original Bill uh written by uh rep
Gordon
um and it's from the findings and
purpose he wrote that in order to comply
with New Hampshire's constitutional
requirements to satisfy statutory
requirements and to maintain the
confidence of the New Hampshire
citizenry in official legislative
activities recusal from voting on any
legislation when there is a conflict of
interest is sometimes required
I don't think I could say it better than
that
um so with that I'll ask the clerk to
call the roll
representative Sheehan yes
representative Osborne
representative rouliard yes
yes clerk votes yes representative Berry
yes representative Wallace yes
representative Smith yes representative
wall
you want to go through everybody
yeah representative Timothy Smith
not here not here no you don't have to I
don't okay that's what I was asking
you'll have to hold on a second
um
the question has been put
any anywhere you want to go but you
won't be involved in this vote
no you didn't ask me oh yes
representative Hill yes
uh the vote is nine zero
in the affirmative
number was nine zero in the affirmative
thank you very much that takes care of
House Bill 1368
um welcome representative
um
we are now working on hcr9
and I should preface this with um well
no I'm going to look for a motion first
on um recommend or not recommend
representative Waller thank you Mr
chairman uh I do not recommend this
for future legislation
is there a second
oh second seconded by a very fine Clerk
representative Simon
um any discussion
if not I will explain the situation just
for the record
um
the original sponsor of the bill was
looking for recognition for
um and a songstress in her his district
was hoping to get some kind of a
certification or or something along
those lines and and was perfectly happy
with getting a certificate from the
speaker
however we still had this bill to deal
with and in an effort to not have it
come out out on the calendar as uh as uh
in expedient to legislate and and cause
difficulty with the constituent
um one of the possible solutions was for
us to put it aside until after the the
ceremony and and she received the
certificate
so this is probably more a housekeeping
issue than anything else so
um I think probably the not recommend
for future legislation is is the only
course of action that we should take so
with that
um no more
future discussion nope
I'll ask the clerk to call the roll
representative Sheehan no representative
Osborne
yes the recommendation is to not
recommend so we would be yes if we
wanted to
not recommend
would you like to I'd like to try that
again yes yes
thank you representative Sheehan
representative Osborne
yeah representative earlier
uh clerk votes yes representative Berry
yes representative Wallace yes
representative Smith yes representative
wall representative Schultz yes
representative Hill yes
vote is 10 to nothing in not recommended
that pretty much concludes our business
for the day I appreciate very much
having our our guests
um
and uh we're all done as a committee I
appreciate everybody and their help for
the year those that aren't coming back
we enjoyed working with you those that
are we will talk with you next year
thank you very much thanks everyone